so you're a money hungry American doctor
in the early 1840s and you have a major
problem see back then being a doctor was
not a prestigious job like it is today
back then being a doctor was considered
a dirty job you dealt with disease germs
sick people it wasn't the high status
profession it is today and on top of
that back then anyone could become a
doctor and because there were so many
doctors you barely made any money
seriously doctors back then were just as
poor as the rest of the middle class
doctors were making a far cry from the
350 000 the average physician makes
today as a doctor back then you spent
your days prescribing stuff like
bloodletting cocaine Mercury and even
lead to your sick patients but with so
many other doctors around you offering
the same treatments as you you had no
choice but to keep pushing your prices
down lower and lower so even though you
know your Mercury and Lead pills are way
better than that doctors over there you
were still not getting paid what you
thought you deserved so something had to
be done so you came up with a brilliant
plan if you could find a way to limit
how many people could become doctors if
you could find a way to gatekeep your
profession to limit the amount of female
doctors poor doctors and Doctors Without
the right education then you would solve
the supply problem and all your
competition all those other doctors will
simply go away while the demand for
doctors would just keep on Rising and so
will your prices if you can control how
many doctors enter the markets you would
have complete control over how much it
costs to save someone's life and all you
have to do to make this dream into a
reality was to find a way to make it
look like what you were doing was in the
best interest of the patients and so
ladies and gentlemen the American
Medical Association was born America's
cartel over the doctor profession
[Music]
back in the 1800s it was ridiculously
easy to become a doctor any man from a
middle-class family could decide that he
wanted to become a doctor then he would
attend a couple lectures he would then
work with another doctor for a while to
gain experience and boom he was ready to
treat patients and prescribe powerful
medicines and if he were from a rich
family and you wanted to treat the
wealthy well maybe you would attend
medical school for a few years but even
that was just mostly reading books and
listening to lectures with zero
practical experience as a result America
became flooded with doctors by the
mid-1800s and for you our ambitious
doctor with Big Dreams that was a
problem you needed to find a way to
massively reduce the number of doctors
in America otherwise there will always
be someone who was willing to offer
their treatment for cheaper than yours
so you got to thinking see back in the
1800s anyone could create medicine and
recommend treatments for common diseases
but not all of these treatments really
made sense like using leeches to suck
out a patient's contaminated blood or
prescribing heroin as cough medication
so what if you created a medical
organization nation that would decide
what medications and treatments worked
and what didn't while at the same time
your organization would only give
certain doctors the right to practice
medicine an organization like that could
conveniently cut down a number of
doctors in America that way all the
official licensed doctors could come
together and decide that yes we would
charge twenty dollars for an amputation
ten dollars for mercury and two dollars
for lead so none of us undercut each
other we're just making these numbers up
on the way if we had a cartel I mean an
association like this none of us would
ever have to worry about other doctors
stealing our clients ever again because
there would be plenty of patience to go
around and every single patient will
have no choice but to suck it up and pay
the price it was the perfect solution to
all your problems and so in 1947 you
founded the American Medical Association
or AMA with the help of some of your
like-minded doctors officially the ama's
mission was to promote the Art and
Science of medicine and the better
treatment of Public Health but you knew
the truth the AMA was your ticket to
controlling the healthcare industry and
you wasted no time I'm getting started
foreign
[Music]
ly after the ama's creation you sent
your representatives to Brad I mean
Lobby the government to get them to pass
strict medical Licensing Laws ah yes now
you needed an official license to
practice medicine and then you asked the
government to set up medical examining
boards now if someone didn't attend
medical school and pass their exams they
would not be able to work or call
themselves a real doctor
now you're probably thinking but Jake
isn't this better than having literally
anyone called themselves a doctor and
treat patients at least these new
doctors were well trained which yes that
is true a lot of snake oil doctors were
cut outs but well trained that's
debatable especially being that today
licensed trained medical doctors only
spend an average of 11 hours learning
about nutrition throughout their entire
education 11 hours and these people tell
you what to eat so well trained again
that's a little debatable but we'll save
that for a future video what isn't
debatable is that with the Advent of the
American Medical Association you now had
an iron grip on the industry and you
took full advantage of laps what this
new licensing scheme the number of
doctors did drop but it still wasn't
enough see the medical schools of the
1800s weren't exactly the same bright
and Shining centers of learning we know
today
getting in was way too easy the lessons
were way too simple and even the exams
were too easy to pass which meant too
many people were graduating
the bar was just set too low so you went
back to the drawing board and came up
with an even better plan reduced the
number of medical schools in the country
to the public you'd say you were doing
it because these medical schools were a
disgrace that they were indescribably
foul and that they were the plague spot
of the nation but in reality you knew
the truth if a hundred medical schools
met that 5 000 doctors graduated every
year then 15 medical schools meant that
only half that amount graduated every
year it was the perfect plan and you had
just the right guy to make it happen a
man named Abraham flexner
[Music]
ha
Abraham flesner was not a doctor but he
was backed by the Carnegie foundation
and apparently that was enough to make
him an expert on what medical school
should and shouldn't look like so in
1910 he published the flexner reports
and just like you had planned flexner
recommended that dozens of sub-centered
medical schools around the country be
shut down immediately so with the
flexing report in hand you sent your
lobbyists back to the governments and
within just a few years eighty percent
of America's medical schools were shut
down 80 percent and by 1940 the ratio of
doctors in America per 100 000 people
fell from 175 doctors to just 125. your
plan had worked thanks to the flexner
reports there were now fewer doctors
than ever graduating from Medical School
quick side note two years after the
flexner report was published Abraham
flexner went on to become a member of
the general education board and served
as the secretary for eight years you
remember the general education board
rights the organization created by John
D Rockefeller to turn the public school
system into the terror torture chamber
is today yeah the same guy that
completely altered the course of Western
medicine was also involved in your
conditioning I mean schooling we have
another video on the story that you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the top right corner and this was just
one way that the flexible report changed
Western medicine forever but we'll save
that for a future video back to the
American Medical Association by the
1940s fewer doctors than ever were
graduating from medical school but still
you weren't satisfied you needed every
one of these doctors to be part of the
AMA to agree to your pricing to solidify
your cartel and so you had to take it
one step further
[Music]
one of the most important stuffs in any
medical student's journey is a medical
residency basically if four years of
pre-med college and another four years
of medical school doesn't weed them out
Med students then need to spend at least
three more years working in a hospital
under the supervision of qualified
doctors to finally get their medical
license or in other words you want to
become a doctor great that will cost you
10 to 14 years and again in those 14
years you're only going to spend 11
hours of that learning about nutrition
so no residency no medical license and
you want to know the convenient thing
about medical residencies it's not just
like medical schools there were only a
few residencies available each year
that's because the salary of resident
doctors are mostly funded by Congress
which means Congress gets to decide how
many residencies American hospitals can
accept every year and between 1987 and
1997 the number of resident doctors in
America grew by almost 21 which was way
too much in her eyes more doctors means
more competition and lower salaries
remember so you sent your trustee
lobbyists back to Capitol Hill this time
to get Congress to drop the number of
residencies it would fund every year why
because according to you America was
about to experience a doctor's Surplus
oh no that would be bad there would be
too many doctors and too few hospitals
for them to work in and Congress ate
that up for some reason so in 1997
Congress ordered the number of new
residencies to be kept and by 2007 the
number of new residencies had only gone
up by measly eight percents and so from
that moment on your cartel was finally
complete you had finally successfully
taken control of every single step in
the road from college student to
resident doctor to official doctor but
there was still one loose end your
outside competition I'm talking midwives
foreign doctors or even worse doctors
that promoted blasphemy like alternative
medicine if your outside competition was
allowed to treat patients they would be
unaltered if you couldn't control and
your doctors would have to go back to
competing on price and services so you
had to crush these alternatives for good
thank you
[Music]
first on your list to destroy were the
midwives the promoters of alternative
medicine typically they would offer
treatments at way lower prices compared
to you and your other doctors so to get
rid of them you reverted back to one of
your oldest strategies calling their
treatments crackery you told the world
that these quack doctors were no better
than the snake oil sellers of the 1800s
every chance you got you told the public
and the government that trusting these
less qualified medical workers was as
good as signing their own death sentence
they didn't have the licenses or the
proper trading to help Going To None was
completely pointless and even dangerous
only a licensed doctor is able to give
real medical advice and it worked the
American public became completely
convinced that licensed doctors were the
only option your Decades of medical
propaganda have worked but you weren't
done yet because next on your list were
foreign doctors think about it if
foreigners were unapproved medical
degrees could just move to America and
work they would heavily undercut your
cartel but luckily getting rid of them
was just as easy all you had to do was
go back to the government once more and
convince the them that foreign doctors
couldn't be trusted who knew what they
taught Med students in strange foreign
countries like England Germany and
France these third world doctors weren't
anywhere close to America's high
standards so if foreign doctors want to
practice in America they would have to
redo their residencies in American
hospitals and pass American Medical
exams it didn't matter if these doctors
had Decades of experience they would
have to start at the bottom like
everyone else fighting for a chance to
get one of those medical residencies
that you got Congress to limit and the
results instead of working as the
qualified doctors they are most skilled
foreign doctors end up teaching or doing
entry-level jobs in hospitals where they
are experienced enough to run the
hospital it was brilliant and with that
the AMA had complete control of
America's supply of doctors while at the
same time your cartel members became
filthy rich
[Music]
foreign
it's April 2016. Charles and Kiera
Johnson made their way to Cedars-Sinai
Hospital in Los Angeles at the hospital
Kira gives birth to a baby boy it's
supposed to be one of the happiest days
of the parents lives but instead it
turns into a nightmare less than half an
hour after the birth Kira experienced a
serious complication as a result of the
C-section panicked Charles calls for
help but instead of running tests and
getting her help right away it took a
doctor eight hours to finally get Kira
back into surgery but by then it was too
late she died on the operating table
with more than 3.5 liters of blood
hemorrhaging into her abdomen and Kira
isn't the only victim the number of
deaths in childbirth in America is
higher than in any other developed
country and one of the reasons for that
is America's insane doctor shortage yes
thanks to the AMA we now have a
legitimate doctor shortage but why
should you care about that sure some
people may be dying because they can't
get access to the right care but at
least today doctors in America are paid
double the amount compared to doctors
and other just as wealthy countries
today almost every medical school
graduate gets Superstar treatment from
the hospitals that need them for
residencies and it's estimated that 10
years from now America will be short
more than 120 000 doctors and yet the
AMA will keep spending more than 21
million dollars a year lobbying the
government to keep it this way a cartel
is defined as an association of
individual Market participants with the
purpose of maintaining prices at a high
level and restricting competition so in
that sense I guess the American Medical
Association achieved their goal
the first step in fixing this Dr cartel
problem is actually getting people to
know that this is a problem which is
what this video is for and another way
is to come up with more effective
treatments for things like cancer so
that treating patients take less time
and effort compared to things like
chemotherapy and one potential new
treatment for cancer is something called
the aflon hemopurifier the aflon
hemopurifier is a device that was
designated by the FDA as a breakthrough
device for treating cancer it does this
by filtering out something called tumor
derived exosomes and life-threatening
viruses from your blood this
breakthrough device is currently in
clinical trials and it's already been
safely administered to 36 patients and
if it works it could help a lot of
people and change the world the company
behind the Athlon hemopurifier is called
aflon medical and they wanted to sponsor
this video to help get the word out
about the work they're doing in their
company they're a public company listed
on the stock market with a lot of cash
on hand and zero deaths and if you're
interested about learning more about
aflon click the square on the screen or
scroll down and click the link below
click the square on the screen or scroll
down and click the link below now thanks
to Athlon medical for being the paid
sponsor of this video Stay dangerous and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]